[Music]
if you're running online retail your
business depends on more than just the
products you offer
you also need to know how they're
selling and how you compare to your
competition
with google market insights we can help
you make the most out of your data
and get insights that you can use to
fuel your growth
getting started with market insights is
easy and only takes two steps
first enable market insights through
merchant center and second
set up the bigquery data transfer
service this won't change how you're
using merchant center to list
and manage your product data you'll now
have access to new data specifically
provided to help you see a bigger
picture
such as seeing how your prices compare
with others and being able to discover
the top selling products and brands
let's see what insights can help you
grow your business by better
understanding how your products are
performing
how they're priced and which products
you should consider adding to your
assortment
we'll start by looking at the overview
of your products to understand how your
products are doing
you need a top-line view of your entire
feed drilling down into your offers by
brand
and category lets you check in on what's
popular and what may need your attention
in addition it's important to keep up to
date with any technical
or policy issues that prevent items from
being listed
once you have a better sense of the
health of your feed you can better
understand how to price products
there's a lot to factor in for pricing
including how your prices
compare to others price benchmarks help
you quickly see where your prices sit
against your competition
and suggest actions you can take
consider letting your customers know
about your competitively priced
offerings
and think about ways to adjust your
pricing for products above the benchmark
but what about the products you're not
carrying with the best sellers report
you can keep an eye on the market and
make sure you're not missing out on any
popular new items
like which brands are selling more than
others this data can also be used to
figure out what categories you could
carry more products in
and what products you can carry
substitutes for when there's high demand
stay informed in areas where you can
grow your business and take action
then measure how you're performing all
from a dashboard built from the market
insights data
these insights can help you understand
the best way to grow but your business
may also have additional first party
data
once you've set up the export the data
is directly accessible in bigquery
from here you can share the data
directly build dashboards with data
studio
or integrate with other tools for
example take your merchant center data
automate weekly reports and business
intelligence tools like looker and
tableau
and build a data pipeline that combines
your selling information with your
supply chain data
combine these out of the box insights
with your own data insights to maximize
the potential for your business
if you want to get started head to the
merchant center to enable market
insights
then set up exporting this data to
bigquery check out the link on screen to
get set up
start using insights to fuel your growth
today
[Music]